a list of my top five Sci-Fi movies that
were bloody perfect welcome to Sidetrack
your SciFi TV and Movie
Channel Perfect movie is there such a
thing I think so yes I think there are
certain movies that they're just utterly
perfect that nothing should change that
every element of the movie was
absolutely spoton but before I tell you
what my top five are and ask you for
your top five I'm going to tell you what
I think makes a perfect sci-fi
movie first of all the casting the
casting has to be right for the roles in
question you don't necessarily need the
best actors in the world you don't
necessarily need the best performances
what you need are the right actors for
the right roles and the right
performance now that is going to be
really important in a couple of the
movies I'm talking about because two of
the films in particular star the same
actor and that actor is not the greatest
actor that's ever lived but he is one of
the greatest action heroes that's ever
lived I think that's a pretty big hint
on where I'm going that but you're going
to have to wait just a minute the story
the story has to be in some way original
now it's very difficult to have a truly
original story anymore but you can tell
a story in an original way or at least
do something original with that story
and I think all of the films I've picked
have done that you know that they've
done that because a lot of those films
are then basically copied in lots of
ways or they actually Define the genre
for a little while I.E a lot of movies
are then influenced by that project you
know when you've done it right basically
when other people imitate you the story
also has to have no major plot holes now
I'm going to be very careful this
because almost every movie ever has some
sort of plot hole you think they didn't
really need to do that they could have
just done this instead and it would have
been much easier but these things have
to happen for the story to happen so
plot holes or bits of the story that
don't really make 100% of sense just
just happens there's nothing we can do
about it it just
happens but no major plot holes a story
that makes sense a story that is logical
in its presentation is vital for a
perfect movie and then finally the movie
has to be exciting now that doesn't
necessarily mean you want to jump up and
punch a bad person in the face but it
has to get your blood flowing it has to
make you want to watch it again and
that's another point the perfect movie
is completely rewatchable it's not the
sort of film you would just watch Once
and go well I've seen it I don't need to
watch it again you will watch it over
and over again and every few years
you'll watch it again because you just
love it so much so what is my list I'm
going to say you in one more second
because the effects effects in a Sci-Fi
movie are important you generally need
special effects CGI models whatever now
some of those effects are going to be
dated but if a filmmaker is clever a lot
of the special effects would really be
timeless and I think you'll find that in
all of the movies I'm going to talk
about they
are the films must be ionic
and by that I mean you will know lines
from the movie even if you're not a
Sci-Fi fan this film appeals to a
massive audience a wide audience because
it's not just a brilliant sci-fi movie
it's just a brilliant movie it has to be
one of those films that people really
geek out over it has to be the sort of
film that people do a million memes
about because it's iconic it has to get
into the core of our culture and it has
to be
influential so what's the first movie on
the list the Matrix now when I first saw
the Matrix my I was seeing this girl at
the time and we walked out and she went
what the bloody hell was that about and
I walked out going oh my God mind blown
I thought it was awesome there was so
many interesting Concepts to this movie
that I just couldn't get my head around
it now I am going to say it's fifth on
my list because I do think it's a little
bit weak in places on the story there
are a few areas where you do
go and the more you actually think about
it the more it maybe you can find a few
plot holes and a few things that few
things that basically don't make sense
but the special effects were
groundbreaking there's no way of arguing
about that it the casting was pretty
much perfect the effort that went into
things like the the martial arts scenes
really did show the commitment from the
actors and the filmmakers it was iconic
it did influence basically an entire
genre of movie and it was replicated a
lot by other films The Matrix sequels
didn't quite live up to the word perfect
I enjoyed them they're good but they're
not perfect The Matrix though was I also
spent several hours explaining the movie
to my girlfriend who then really weirdly
wasn't my girlfriend for very long after
go
figure Jurassic Park is probably the
best movie on my list from many
different ways of looking at it it was
obviously one of the most popular movies
ever made the special effects were not
just groundbreaking they still look
amazing today I actually saw this on the
cinema for the first time in ages um
during the pandemic when we weren't
locked down but there were no films
coming out and um I on the big screen it
still looked phenomenal the story is
brilliant there's are no plot holes in
it the only reason it's a little bit
lower on my list is because it's less of
a science fiction movie and more of a
monster movie in places and even though
it is still science fiction because it's
based on science and it's fiction um it
does feel more of a monster movie really
um but it is one of the greatest films
ever made and again I wouldn't change a
damn thing about
it the first movie with the actor I
mentioned earlier is Terminator 2 now
the
Terminator would come very close to
Perfection it was an excellent movie um
I actually think really it deserves
probably to be on this list and it
probably does deserve and I'm actually
certain many of you will probably say it
is perfect and I wouldn't argue with you
the special effects were brilliant
Michael bien was brilliant I actually
think I'm not sure I'm saying bien right
but anyway um I just think he's one of
my favorite actors he's also in Aliens
which comes very close to this list as
well and I actually really struggled
over whether to add it or not and really
Terminator one and two probably deserve
to be on this list Terminator 2 though
deserves a little bit more credit
because for one it's a sequel that's
actually better than the original that
doesn't happen very often was very
clever in the way it twisted a lot of
the story from the original and then
used elements from the original to add
drama and tension to the sequel the
whole fact that Arnold schwarzeneger is
The Terminator in the second one is
brilliant and really did add a very
clever element to the initial part of
the movie you were expecting to go one
way then it just veered and went
completely the other I love that and to
be honest the way the movie ended
probably should have been the end of the
franchise if I'm 100% honest but again
it ended in such a way that you were
begging for more excitement is not even
it's off the scale with this film the
casting is off the scale and as I say
even though the Terminator original
probably deserves to be on the list as
well Terminator 2 is genuinely one of my
favorite films ever made and as I say
Arnold Schwarzinger not the greatest
actor on the planet but absolutely
perfect for this
role
another movie with Michael bien I'm
still not sure I'm saying that right I
really should probably check on the
internet how to say his name but screw
it i'm G to move on the abyss now
obviously James Cameron did the
Terminator James Cameron also did the
abyss James Cameron is a freaking genius
and he does movies well let's be honest
now I could have added the Avatar onto
this film but it's that rewatchability
bit that I really can't add it I find
the movie the first Avatar and the
second avatar just wet Avatar a little
boring they're too long they're even
even though they are beautifully made
and the special effects again are just
beyond another tier it loses points for
me on the
excitability The Abyss on the other hand
doesn't the abyss had special effects in
it than we'd never seen before and blew
our fragile Minds I also have to admit I
love any movie that nearly kills most of
its cast Ed Harris talked about how he
nearly drowned two or three times and um
most of the cast said that even though
working on the movie was one of the most
amazing experiences in their lives they
would never do it again and I have to
admit I love that sort of level of
commitment maybe from more more from
James Cameron than the actors because
I'm not sure the actors actually knew
what they were signing up for but the
story was again not what you expect all
the way through the film you expect it
to go one way and then just because
James Cameron is a goddamn genius it
twists and goes the other I love things
like the platform and I don't know why
but it just really appeals to me that
underwater platform the submergible and
the way the everything work the
machinery and the mechanical um element
of the film I love the way Michael Ian's
character just went nuts and completely
want of fun and that you think the
alien's going to be the villain but then
it actually turns out to be us that's
the villain because he gets the bend
it's not even his fault that he goes
crazy um it's just a really twisty turny
movie that doesn't meet any of your
expectations instead it completely
throws curveballs at you and creates
whole new expectations for every other
film you ever watch now that is a hell
of a movie the abyss is maybe not as
iconic as the other movies on this list
it maybe didn't have the wide Universal
appeal the other movies on the list had
but it should have done there are
elements of this film that
are truly amazing the special effect of
the alien coming up through the water
has been replicated by movies ever
bloody since it influenced so many Movie
Makers it's not even funny
the movie is Iconic even if a lot of
people maybe haven't watched it for
years they
should what is the top movie on my list
the most perfect sci-fi movie as far as
I'm concerned the most perfect sci-fi
movie ever made as far as I'm concerned
now I'm going to say to you again there
are certain movies through the years
that I just think are genre defining
films Die Hard is a genre defining
action movie it completely flipped what
an action movie was and basically
everyone tried to copy it ever since
Lethal Weapon is similar and basically
the list goes on but as a sci-fi movie
the most perfect is the Predator Arnold
Schwarz Carl Weathers even Jesse
Ventura are perfectly cast in this
film they're again not the greatest
actors in the world but they don't need
to be because they're perfect for the
role they're playing the storyline was
pretty bloody original at the time even
though it's been repeated and I've tried
to be copied a million times since back
when this film was released my God it
blew our minds we had never seen
anything quite to this level before also
I should say the special effects stand
up today because they they kept them
simple they didn't try to go too far
they just did what they were able to do
and they did it bloody
brilliantly this film does make you at
the end want to go and find a bad person
and and defeat them it's incredibly
exciting you get pumped as a I mean as a
Blog I watch films like this and you
know it just makes you want to go and
hit the gym you know it's it's makes you
want to go be manly this film had such
an impact on me that I've probably
watched it 30 or 40 times I loved the
sequel but it's not as good as the
original they've made good Predator
movies since I actually liked the
Predators I thought that was pretty good
um the Predator was crap but um AP
pretty good in places but the Predator
it went so far beyond what other
filmmakers were making at the time that
it made them look dated it made them
look lazy this film was perfect in
almost every aspect and is completely
iconic I actually think this movie is
the film that propelled Arnold Schwarz
into super stardom he actually
fills the role of Dutch perfectly in
almost every way but to be honest the
entire cast is absolutely spoton for a
film that really nobody that I know
dislikes there are loads of stories
about how horrifically difficult this
movie was to make out in the jungle the
actors did not have a good time there
were leeches stifling humidity horrific
terrain to be honest terrain you can see
in the films but there were just so many
iconic moments like get to the choer
later in the movie when Billy decides to
uh stand up to the predator and uh that
doesn't last
long he really shouldn't have cut
himself with the knife surely that's
weakening himself before the fight
surely you should be know like taking
like an eating an energy bar or
something but it's an iconic moment
where Billy sacrifices himself and
attempt to give Dutch and the rest a
fighting chance just to delay the
predator for those few minutes they
needed to get to the choer but one of
the biggest and most interesting parts
of this movie is that you take a
character like Arnold Schwarzenegger big
powerful and you flip it because the
Predator is bigger more powerful Dutch
realizes very quickly that he cannot for
once fight his way out of a situation he
can't muscle his way out of a situation
and he has to fight smart they took a
very powerful human being and made him
look weak that is one of the most
important and iconic parts of this film
it's probably the greatest movie for me
ever made but guys I would love to to
know what you think of my top five list
also what other movies would you add to
it not your favorites because that might
be a little bit different perfect movies
movies that you just watch and go I
wouldn't change anything for me maybe
like Star Trek The Wrath of KH other
films like that if you're talking about
just sci-fi might have an argument to
get on this list as I said Avatar maybe
if that's a movie you adored what list
would you have what are the perfect top
five films that you would pick get into
the comments and tell everyone if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com citrek where most of
our new videos Premiere first and you
get to see them without the
adverts also you can go to
c.c. where we do articles based on a lot
of our stories and we Tred to add a
little bit more information for you to
digest go check it out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next
[Music]
time